A1 A2 B1 B2 C1 and C2 these are the
common levels that we use labels that we
use in order to define the language
skills of a learner for me actually
there are mainly two levels or two
phases or two areas of language learning
that of the language learner and that of
the language user what's the difference
between these two well a language
learner is someone who sits down and
hits the books in order to um get the
get a solid foundation in a language
when you're in this phase you're still
not able to understand um the spoken
language so you're listening
comprehension is poor and you have to
rely on scripts transcriptions uh
subtitles if you're watching videos so
that is the phase where you have to
learn the language as an
adult and that is a phase where you need
discipline you need to sit down and you
have to make it happen every day
otherwise you don't build the So-Cal
language core and that language core
shrinks with time in this phase what you
need is discipline discipline is key to
make it happen every day you cannot rely
on motivation because if you rely on
motivation what is going to happen is
that maybe you're going to hit the books
for a week or a month but then
inevitably life gets in the way your
motivation wains and tapers off and then
one day you just stop learning and
that's it but then you have the language
user phase so let's that you've been
learning a language for one year or
maybe two years and you've reached
fluency you've reached that stage where
you can actually use the language with
people that is the language user phase
and in that phase what you need is
courage not discipline anymore but
courage let me tell you a story um 3
months ago I was in Greece and that was
the very first time that I was in Greece
speaking Greek now I've been learning
Greek for five long years and I've been
listening to podcast test and watching
videos every single day so I believe
that my listening comprehension is good
and my speaking skills are relatively
decent cuz I've been working with a
couple of tutors but the thing is that
when I tried to order something at the
restaurant or when I was having even um
a short conversation with someone a
waiter um or anything else I felt a
little bit of anxiety I don't know if
you've ever felt this kind of anxiety
but it's that moment when you're
experiencing something that is old and
you at the same time it's old because
you've already ordered something at the
restaurant in your native language or
some other language you've already
talked to some people you already
interacted in the same way in certain
situations and
circumstances but you've never done it
in this new language in my case that was
Greek I had never interacted with people
in Greek and the highlight of my journey
in Greece was when I had to record a
video with a legendary from Easy Greek I
was terrorized and paralyzed because I
knew that hundreds of people or maybe
thousands of people would watch that
video and in that moment um I told
myself you know what let's jump in maybe
I'm going to make mistakes maybe some
word will not come that happened by the
way but I just wanted to communicate and
I think that the biggest Point here was
that I just made it happen I just
ordered something at the restaurant I
talk to people in Greek I made a video
with legendary Dimitri and I feel
stronger so what you need is courage as
a language user when once you start once
you accumulated enough knowledge to use
the language what you have to do is use
it interact with people connect with
people make mistakes sometimes you will
find yourself in awkward situations but
that is worth it every single experience
is worth it I like thinking that fluency
is a measure of confidence that you have
and you don't measure flu inuencing not
just in terms of words or phrases that
you know not just in how good your
pronunciation your grammar is but also
in the amount of experiences that you
live and the more experiences you live
the more awkward situations and elating
situations you're going to uh find
yourself in so just to sum up um if
you're a language uh learner if you're a
beginner or a high beginner what is
important is discipline in order to hit
the books in order to learn every day in
order to build that discipline that you
need in order to reach fluency and once
you've reached fluency let's say B2 once
you're able to use the language use it
as much as you can find yourself in as
many situations as possible face the
unknown face your fears because when you
do that when you live these situations
your confidence will grow step by step
and then you'll find yourself wanting to
use this language more and more and that
language will become part of your life
thank you so much and as always happy
language learning